die regierung reagiert heute gab
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck
bekannt dass gaslieferant uniqa
verstaatlicht wird kostenpunkt 15
milliarden euro weitere systemrelevante
betriebe könnten folgen gerettet dass
die deutsche wirtschaft die opposition
hat er ihre zweifel und außerdem immer
mehr flüchtlinge kommen nach deutschland
auch über das mittelmeer können wir uns
das leisten
das möchte ich heute mit meinen gästen
besprechen ex fdp chefin und chemikerin
frauke petry sagt bestellt wie gewählt
und jetzt das böse erwachen grüne vision
werden wahr bild chefredakteur und tv
chef claus strunz sieht eine
flüchtlingskrise 2.0 auf uns zurollen
auch mit von der partie die ehemaligen
grünen politikerin und energie expertin
antje hermenau sieht sich sicher es gibt
kaum alternativen zum russischen gas der
landesvorsitz der cdu hamburg und
bundestagsabgeordnete christoph ploß
fordert die verlängerung der kernkraft
jede kilowattstunde zählt das ist ein
motto schön dass sie alle da sind es war
eigentlich relativ klar dass mit den
grünen in der regierung die atomkraft
nicht angesagt sein wird und mancher
wähler bereit jetzt gar den grünen seine
stimme gegeben zu haben frau gebeten
überrascht das nicht und ihr thema heute
abend ist die grüne götterdämmerung
eigentlich bekommen die wähler oder
deutschland gerade das nicht nur was sie
dieses mal gewählt haben sondern auch
was sie über legislaturen gewählt haben
denn wenn man sagt grüne politik ist
überall dann kann man tatsächlich
verstellen dass alle parteien auch
einfach an die cdu ihre partei floss
über jahre legislaturen die politik
gemacht haben die grünen jetzt auch
praktisch wieder an die macht gebracht
hat der ausstieg aus der kernkraft die
verdammung der kohleenergie vieles
andere mehr das märchen von der
energieverknappung als neue religion ist
nichts kurzfristiges war über jahrzehnte
angelegt gewesen und ein bisschen auch
die deutsche gutgläubigkeit und
vielleicht sogar die gut gemeinte
absicht alles richtig zu machen und vor
allen dingen alles richtig als alle
anderen nationen und genau daran drohen
wir jetzt zu scheitern nicht nur im
eigenen land sondern mit den
europäischen verbund reißen die
nachbarstadt in europa mit ins
energetische unglück und treffen wird
ist wie immer die mittelschicht und die
ärmsten der gesellschaft all diejenigen
die heute ihr einkommen noch selbst
erwirtschaften können und möglicherweise
in den nächsten jahren von staatlichen
transfers ab unabhängig sein werden denn
1 300 euro zuschuss wird nicht reichen
wenn die energierechnung die gasrechnung
die stromrechnung pro monat um mehrere
hundert euro steigt und deswegen ist es
eigentlich ein desaster und ich kann nur
hoffen dass viele der bürger die aus
gutem willen grüne gewählt haben jetzt
merken dass diese art von politik in die
absolute mangelwirtschaft führt und dazu
kann ich nur sagen als gelernter
ddr-bürger mangelwirtschaft kennen von
den rund 80 millionen deutschen bisher
maximal 16 millionen auch vielleicht die
jungen leute gar nicht mehr ich finde
nicht dass es ein ziel sein sollte dass
weitere 60 oder 56 millionen diese art
von mangel wirtschaft kennen lernen sie
trifft auch daran dass fragen wieder
einmal frau hermenau sie als ex grüne
ist der vorwurf zu hart oder angebracht
dass wir mit den grünen die
mangelwirtschaft kennenlernen werden wir
werden die warenwirtschaft kennen lernen
und es hat auch was mit der ansage zu
tun dass wir uns bescheidener verhalten
sollen das wurde ja ein relativ
gekleidet das finde ich sehr defensiv
wir sind eigentlich eine
industrienationen und nicht so ein
kleiner fan austria sondern wir wollen
eigentlich vorne mitspielen das tun wir
übrigens auch immer sich die zahlen vor
corinna mal anguckt gab es nur drei
länder auf der welt die insgesamt
überhaupt in der lage waren für mehr als
1000 milliarden us-dollar
dienstleistungen und güter zu
exportieren china die usa und
deutschland also england und frankreich
wissen schon zusammen legen im export um
auf deutsche größen zu kommen und das
riskieren wir gerade ganz massiv ich
verstehe nicht wie man umverteilungs
träume haben kann egal ob in die soziale
schiene oder in die ökologische china
wenn man kein geld erwirtschaftet ist
unklar
herb los da kann man jetzt mal fragen es
ist ja jetzt nicht so als hätte nur spd
und fdp mit den grünen sympathisieren in
der union haben wir auch einige mit
schwarz grün vor der wahl geliebäugelt
wer das jetzt noch eine option für sie
also ich werde erst mal kurz zu dem was
sagen was frau petra winter und was bei
ihm ja auch durchschimmerte die union in
schuld und erstmalig ein bisschen für
die union war drei monate alt waren
jetzt kommt erst
gar nicht in große werbeblock einführen
ich will auch sagen natürlich hätte man
mit dem wissen von heute früh auch
einiges anders machen müssen und
natürlich sind auch entscheidungen die
vor einigen jahren getroffen worden aus
heutiger sicht falsch man musste nur
auch sagen im nachhinein ist man immer
klüger und spätestens nach dem 24
februar dem angriffskrieg von russland
auf die ukraine hätte man umsteuern
müssen und sagen müssen die
energiepolitik deutschlands die kann
nicht mehr auf gas basieren und es
müssen alternativen her neben den
erneuerbaren und da glaube ich dass
kernkraft eine wichtige rolle spielen
wird aber vielleicht darf ich das kurz
dazwischen gehen denn tatsächlich ich
verstehe dass sie als cdu politiker ihre
partei verteidigen aber das ist so wie
2015 dafür sozusagen das war ein
naturereignis wir konnten das feuer
nicht wissen und das was jetzt gerade in
der energiepolitik passiert ist ein
scheitern verzeihung mit ansage wir
wissen seit langer zeit dass uns die
erneuerbaren energien keine grundlast
bringen dass wir am ende uns von putin
abhängig machen konnte man sehen wenn
man die menge russischen gases man sich
langsam die wir von dort exportieren und
die fdp ist nicht so wahrgenommen dass
endlich immer von mutter abkoppeln
wollte
die energiepolitik der leckeren
legislaturen da müssen wir feststellen
dass merkel ja auch gegen den willen der
fatah die jeweilige solange die selbst
und diese abkehr von der kernkraft
umgesetzt hat und ich habe gerade noch
mal nachgeschaut nur um da die fdp nicht
raus zu lassen es war ein fdp politiker
der mitte der neunziger jahre
den ruf nach fünf d-mark politik benzin
in die welt gesetzt hat es wird über den
grünen zugeschrieben die wahl
tatsächlich damit beteiligt und haben es
beschlossen aber es waren fdp politiker
und zwar der chef des umweltbundesamtes
der 21 jahre diese behörde geleitet hat
der hat diese forderung in gang ist und
zwar warum um die autofahrer dazu zu
bewegen das auto stehen zu lassen und
das ist doch was das größte deutsche
problem die versuchen ständig als
politiker die bürger zu erziehen aber
das ist gar nicht unsere aufgabe wird er
jetzt jetzt muss ich einmal hat
widersprechen weil weil sie
wir haben früher ja auch verantwortung
getragen auch in der hfg und die alte
war immer die partei in deutschland bis
heute die eine ganz ganz enge beziehung
zu risse und gesucht aber reden die
probleme bleiben der verhandlungen und
die bis heute sagt ist sollen witziges
beziehung mit putin russland geben also
gerade ihr erfährt ja nicht raus gelernt
und aber das ist jetzt nicht aber sie
haben damals ja auch nicht gesagt also
die energie beziehungen abgebrochen wird
das leiden einmal bei der energiepolitik
und da würde ich dich gerne fragen
clausus kam es darüber als wäre erst
durch den angriffskrieg der ukraine klar
geworden was falsch zu diesem land läuft
energiepolitisch ist es die da auch erst
klar geworden also ich das jetzt
angehört und so und wenn nicht alles so
traurig wären wenn wir nicht wirklich
vollendet intel sitzen würden und wenn
ich leute von pleite und sozialer armut
bedroht werden dann müsste man
eigentlich schmunzeln über alles weil
wir werden ja zeuge eines groß
angelegten sozialexperiment ich glaube
viele wähler der grünen wollten gar
nicht die grünen wählen sondern die
wollten nur dass ich mal was ändert dass
man dieses großkoalitionäre zeug zu ende
ist und eigentlich waren sie die ideen
mit dem lastenfahrrad und so auch ganz
niedlich und dann hat man gedacht jetzt
probieren wir es mal so das finde ich
erst mal okay klar muss jedem
verständigen menschen gewesen sein dass
das der einstieg in den umbau einer
gesellschaft ist denn wir haben ja jetzt
eine linke regierung die ist nicht ganz
doll links aber sie ist links und sie
hat einen kleinen gelben wichtel man auf
der kasse sitzen mit dem christian
lindner als finanzminister der sich
jeden tag überlegen muss ob er den
scheiß mit macht und dann weiter an der
macht bleibt oder irgendwann mal gesagt
ich mach nicht mehr mit und alles in die
luft jagt da besteht erhält morgens auf
schaut sich ein spiel gehen und sagt es
gar nicht so schlecht minister zu sein
und dann macht dass wir damit
das ist die situation die ist aber nicht
vom himmel gefallen um auf deine frage
zu machen sondern das konnte jedes haben
wir in diesem studio haben wir das
beschrieben wir haben es diskutiert und
geschrieben dann sind angegriffen worden
als zukunftsverweigerer
prototypen als sonst irgendwas und jetzt
ist es halt so gekommen jetzt muss man
sagen bei lac pech für die grünen und
der spd das jetzt so viele krisen auf
einmal kommen bei denen sie in jeder
einzelnen versagen weil sie den falschen
politischen kompass als grundlage haben
nämlich ein sie haben es angedeutet der
staat muss alles richten und man muss
die menschen umziehen wir reden ja jetzt
noch gar nicht darüber dass da auch
eingepreist ist wie man sich benehmen
soll was man sagen soll wir wissen dass
eine landung soll jetzt der nächste
knüller man soll also nur noch auf so
und soviel quadratmetern wohnen und wenn
man kinder hat dann kann man eine
größere wohnung nehmen oder oder bauen
aber das wollen wir gleich sozusagen
zwei türen einbauen damit man die kinder
aus dem haus sind bloß nicht zu viel
wohnraum hat die die bauministerin hat
solche lustigen träume aber das ist
alles nicht von heute auf morgen geboren
waren das stand immer überall und es war
klar wer das rot grün wird mit ein
bisschen gelb oder gar nur und grün dann
kommt das alles und ich glaube auch dass
man da so schnell nicht mehr raus kommt
insofern sind diejenigen die das mal so
als versuche in ihren prenzlauer berg
und münchen grünwald wohnungen mal somit
überlegt haben das könnte man doch mal
so machen und so die sind jetzt
mittäter eines umbaus einer eines großen
gesellschaftlichen umbaus und die cdu
und besonders zu sagen hat sich
natürlich in den jahren zuvor in den
großen fragen um die es geht auch nicht
mit ruhm bekleckern migrationspolitik
sprechen wir später drüber
energiepolitik das haben wir schon los
war als andere natürlich alles richtig
gelaufen ist aber vielleicht können sie
neue ideen für die nächsten wochen und
monate die leute haben einerseits an
aber sowas von vorbei uns früher selbst
das telefon ist also das macht
nachdenklich
bringt regen so kommen die menschen noch
mehr weibliche für stück kuchen einladen
ich habe gesehen drei stück kuchen noch
einen anderen dazu trage ich die kugel
euro staates geladen ist das in ordnung
komplexen kaffee so ist die lage also
die leute haben eine vorsprache angst
dass sie in ein paar wochen schon nicht
mehr der lage sein werden ihren normalen
alltag zu finanzieren denen sie gewohnt
sind wir reden darüber dass sich strom
und gaspreis das wird sich noch eine
weile hinziehen das schon streck betrieb
so auch in der preisentwicklung aber da
kommt dass die steigen zwei drittel der
inflation dient die haben sie jetzt vor
der haustür stehen und zweistellig
werden wird sind über die energiepreise
ein drittel sind andere geschichten
denke ich so ungefähr alles in ordnung
das problem ist wir haben also vor
dieser energiekrise sind da übrigens nur
europa steckt kein anderer kontinent nur
europa hat dieses problem das hat auch
viel mit dem mit der vor wut wir sind
die besten hat er da auch ein bisschen
den eindruck dass die deutschen wiederum
in europa besonders viel von diesem
problem angekommen aber der punkt auf
den ich hinaus will ist die am haben
diese probleme nicht wir haben das
problem das treibt die preise nach oben
wir sind die armen schweine die teuer
bezahlen müssen für das was sie wollen
wir haben also pipeline das gas zur
hälfte billiger sag ich mal ungefähr als
das lg das dann irgendwann mal aus
amerika mit schweröl betrieben großen
tanker rübergeschickt wird ökologisch
einen der sache kommen wir später konnte
habe ich mich noch ein punkt ja wir
haben früher für sag ich mal eine
megawattstunde strom
haben wir vielleicht so um die 50 bis 60
euro bezahlt wir sind jetzt in einer
price range von 200 bis 300 euro sagen
wir 250 euro pro megawattstunde und das
bleibt die nächsten jahre so weil wir
keine infrastruktur haben um irgendetwas
zu ändern wir müssten eigentlich mit
jedem dämlichen dynamo den wir irgendwo
haben jedes kraftwerk alles was wir
haben selber strom produzieren hier in
deutschland selbst produzieren und zwar
stand peter damit wir der lage sind die
preis zu senken diese verfünffachung der
preise können wäre der mittelstand noch
die bürger ertragen es wird nicht
funktionieren